ce qui est inquiétant c'est le
développement d'une culture autoritaire
je crois que c'est quelque chose de
grave c'est quelque chose
d'international on voit bien que le
grand message de la victoire
démocratique qui a coïncidé avec
l'effondrement
de l'empiré soviétique
il ya trente ans ce grand message
s'estompe profondément les pays qui se
sont débarrassés du communisme renoue
avec l'autoritarisme
jusque et y compris au sein de l'union
européenne
comme on le voit avec les évolutions
quand même préoccupante de pays comme la
hongrie ou comme la pologne donc là il
ya quelque chose de nouveau et de très
grave parce que il est difficile de
concevoir un système
satisfaisant qui repose sur le fait que
le pouvoir politique ne procède pas de
la libre décision des citoyens dans le
cadre d'un débat pluraliste et
respectueux il est adroit ans c'est vers
ça que un peu partout dans le monde même
en europe et même en france on tend peu
d des candidats à la présidence de la
république comme monsieur zemmour ou
comme madame le pen qui représente donc
beaucoup de voir trouve que c'est un
facteur de légitimité d'aller chez
monsieur or ban en hongrie partager un
système véritablement autoritaire et
qu'on fiscale soir des libertés c'est
préoccupant on sent bien que toute
l'europe hésite
toute l'europe hésite mais elle s'est
souvent bonsoir garder les élections
allemandes très profondément les partis
populistes extrémistes ont marqué le
palais les partis vainqueurs et même le
grand party vaincu la cd ou les quatre
parties ils tiennent vraiment solidement
lol
le pays je crois que heureusement le
le populisme et est soluble dans la
démocratie
un grand pays comme la pologne la
société est profondément partager je
pense que l'avenir quand vous regardez
les classes l'âge l'avenir appartient
plutôt au démocrate en hongrie vous
voyez par exemple que les villes ne sont
pas favorables à robin notamment du dap
est en turquie tout ce qui est jeune
moderne nouveaux rebelles à la dictature
erdogan yens donc non le heureusement le
combat n'est pas perdu et et nous devons
effectivement
l'organiser et le gagner